sound versus Goma arguably the most
memorable confrontation from Dragonball
to date and it's easy to see why there's
a lot of moving parts here from Goku
surrender and Gohan's initial flurry to
the iconic transformations and heroic
motivational speeches and sacrifices but
this iconic scene has had many different
iterations over the last 25 years and
today I will be focusing and reviewing
four of them progressing in order of
release I will first look at the
original 1993 Japanese broadcast
followed by the Funimation edit and
dubbed from the early 2000s Dragon Ball
Z Kai from 2011 and you might think I'm
crazy but team four stars 2018 parody
will be what I will look at closely - to
round off the four options but unlike my
other videos the interesting thing about
this one is that I won't be the one
making the final decision at the end you
will once each of these iterations have
been reviewed and broken down I will at
the end of the video offer you the
viewer a chance to vote in a poll for
your fav foretelling of this epic clash
now with that out of the way let's begin
with the very first airing of this
legendary scene and to do that we have
to go all the way back to the original
Japanese broadcast from 1993 this is the
original broadcast version of the show
that aired on Japanese televisions in
the late 80s and early 90s brought in
from episodes 181 to 191 for a total of
10 episodes it also boasts an incredible
score by should escape Kikuchi and has
the incredibly catchy and timeless
opening theme some chawla head chala by
Hironobu Kageyama specific to the Gohan
vs. self fight Kageyama also sang on
mega heave which was a song made and
produced specifically for that moment
when Gohan transform it's a favourite
among those that enjoyed the original
Japanese dump in terms of voice acting
the original voice of Goku and Gohan
is Mosco Nozawa ryo horikawa plays
vegeta norio wakamoto played south may
you meet Tanaka was Krillin Toshio
Furukawa was piccolo Joe Gianna me as
Kim Chi and Takashi ku sail as Future
Trunks from a visual and story
standpoint for decades this was
considered the gold standard for Dragon
Ball in
mindset anyways still is depending on
your point of view it had violence
wonderful music and superb voice acting
however due to the nature of anime a
considerable amount of filler was added
to the fight instead of the dominating
and Swift fashion Gohan dismantled cell
in in the manga this version of the
story showcases a substantially longer
altercation between the two fighters the
most noticeable differences this led to
included mr. Satan's entourage
participating in the Cell Games a longer
overall fight between Sal and Gohan as
well as an extended conclusion to the
fight where piccolo tension
Krillin and even Yamcha took part in
helping beat cell depending on what sort
of viewer you are and what you want from
your entertainment this can be viewed as
yet another positive or perhaps a
negative next up is the early Funimation
English dub original release the year
2000 for the vast majority of English
speakers this version of events acted as
their introduction to the story and
world of dragon ball rolling from
episodes 166 to 176
this version much like the original
lasted 10 episodes in total however
despite that similarity it was distinct
from its original counterpart for many
reasons one of the most celebrated
reasons was a score created by Bruce
Faulkner this soundtrack creates a very
different atmosphere - it's more
orchestral predecessor in the original
Japanese broadcast with this soundtrack
there's a distinct focus on a more
new-age synth rock genre which is
finally remembered by those that enjoyed
this version of the series
notable tracks include the themes for
Vegeta and for sale among others
[Music]
aside from Bruce Faulkner's tracks the
opening theme rocked the Dragon was an
earworm for many who grew up with it's
catchy hook and shredding guitar music
definitely a product of its time but
that's certainly not a bad thing passing
the role of Goku and King Kai was Shawn
civil as Yamcha Vegeta and piccolo was
Christopher Sabbat Sal was voiced by
Damian Clark and Gohan was voiced by
Stephanie Nadal the script that was
composed for this version the story has
been criticized harshly since its
release however among fans of this
version they similarly find it difficult
to enjoy the original version due to the
significant differences in presentation
when it comes to script voice acting and
musical score however just like its
Japanese counterpart this show presents
the same extended fight scenes and
visual fluff ie mr. Satan's entourage a
major difference in tone can be observed
with this particular English iteration
in scenes words the Japanese broadcast
opted to keep things quiet this English
telling would play music loudly or have
characters monologue in their minds
where the originals never would have the
most obvious example of this would be
Gohan's monologue to himself
right before he transforms in the
original Japanese broadcast Gohan remain
silent now let's fast-forward to Dragon
Ball Z Kai original release 2011 after
almost two decades toh en Shueisha
decided to remake the original Dragon
Ball anime in a sense with all new voice
acting and a significant amount of
filler removed the new Dragon Ball Z Kai
was made with many of the voices to save
in both English and Japanese versions
returning speaking to the Gohan vs. elf
ice this ran from episodes 90 to 96 for
a total of seven episodes three fewer
than both the original broadcast and
it's early Funimation dubbing along with
all new voice acting Dragon Ball Kai
came with all new music the opening
theme song Dragon Soul was upbeat number
performed by tacca Yoshi Tanimoto
however the score for the series
excluding the Buu saga was by kenji
yamamoto who was later found to have
plagiarized a number of
prax on the series nora hito tsunetomo
replaced yamamoto for the Buu saga
finishing off the Chi series in the
fight itself but the filler was removed
however some persisted in the form of
again mr. Singh's entourage some of the
Super Saiyan 2 Gohan vs. cell fight and
the ending in which cell is ganged up on
by every available fighter in this case
not much was added and in some cases
violence blood and injury was toned down
and now finally our fourth entry team
four stars Dragon Ball Z abridged salad
vs. go on original release 2018 now I
know I'm gonna be hearing a lot of
voices calling me out for including this
particular version of the story but
believe it or not this telling of events
in some respects is closer to the manga
than the others at least in the visual
capacity but I'm getting ahead of myself
here broken up into three individual
parts team four stars telling of the go
on vs cell fight has a total running
time of just over an hour and eight
minutes similar to the 1993 version of
the story team four star have opted to
use the Kikuchi score which sets a nice
tone for emotional moments in the story
[Music]
I guess I should go clean up my mess huh
however they also decided to include
their own music in some parts through
original pieces covers or remixes to
scores and tracks from pre-existing
tellings of the story like Bruce
falconers Vegeta theme scene during the
final flash earlier in the story and
cells theme throughout however musically
highlight has to be their English cover
of unmanned no high now renamed day of
fete performed by Paulo Cuevas and Annie
Joe Geryon the voices provided for this
scene are Lauren Simpson as Gohan and
Goku kurz are not as cell Scott Frerichs
as Future Trunks and King Kai and Nick
Landis as piccolo Vegeta and krillen
while the dialogue and tone is stretched
and altered beyond recognition to
accommodate a more comedic Sensibility
this telling of the clash between Gohan
and cell at least from a visual
perspective is closer to the manga in
ways the others have not been and I
thought it worth including for that very
reason for example go on in the original
tongues of the story sparse for a short
time and not so short time would sell
before ultimately outclassing him TFS
opted to remain closer to the manga
dismantling Cell in a few blows
completely out classic additionally
considerable efforts were made to remove
mr. Satan's entourage to bring it closer
to the manga also as they much like the
manga did not appear at all in this
version
similarly the father son Kamehameha has
a noticeable difference to the other
entries in that piccolo Krillin Yamcha
and tension hun don't participate at all
allowing Vegeta to buddy at the end to
help Gohan with that final push just
like the manga did the visual story
shown and these choices made might be
difference makers for some but I can
also appreciate for others that the
jokes and narrative changes made might
be too much to consider this an option
so as promised now that I have broken
down the original in 1993 the early
Funimation in 2000 the Dragon Ball Kai
2011 and the TFS versions from 2018 I
would like to present you with the
opportunity to cast your vote which
interpretation of the events outlined do
you think presented at best a card to
cast your vote should appear in the top
right of the screen click it and choose
your favorite I do apologize for not
including a Spanish dub of this section
or any other job that you might have
enjoyed growing up with unfortunately I
am limited by my understanding of just
one language and I wouldn't feel
comfortable speaking in detail about
something I have no experience with I
hope you understand and still had a
horse to back in this race I am
genuinely excited to see what the
results of this poll might be and if
this is a format that you guys and gals
enjoyed then I'll break down more in the
future but before that let me know what
you thought of this video
and if you have any suggestions for
another scene I should review and
compare be sure to leave them down below
in the comment section and who knows I
might do it don't forget to leave a like
or dislike on this video and I will see
you all in the next one thank you so
much for watching
[Music]